i used to have a rule that i implemented
for myself no technology within arm's
reach of the bed
however ever since i got an m1 ipad pro
that rule has been absolutely shattered
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas welcome back to the channel today
we're looking at the m1 ipad pro from
somebody who's owned it literally from
day one when it came out if you haven't
seen that video where i talked about the
m1 ipad pro for architects when i first
got it and all the pros and cons i saw
for justifying the purchase i'll link it
up top and down below so you can check
it out but today i wanted to share with
you my long-term thoughts of owning this
device it's been just under six months
now since i received the delivery and
took ownership of the highly expensive
m1 ipad pro and to this day it has been
incredible there definitely has been
some shortfalls which i'll get into a
little bit later on but i wanted to
start with some great news because it
has been the be-all end-all for me
moving in to the apple ecosystem now
like i said in the intro of this video i
used to have that rule no technology
within arm's reach of the bed that meant
no phone no laptop no ipad no nothing
and genuinely i stuck to that rule for
as long as i can remember because still
to this day my phone sits on the other
side of the room plugged in on the floor
because i don't want any distractions
before i go to bed
however the ipad actually completely
shattered this rule and changed the game
for me it is the only device that sits
literally on my bedside table from the
moment i wake up it's picked up and from
the moment i go to bed it's put back
down
it does not leave my side it is the
ultimate all-in-one computer ipad
experience absolutely everything now
from somebody who's been a massive
samsung user and a windows user for so
long i really push myself into not going
down the apple ecosystem unfortunately
for me i bought the m1 ipad pro and am
now contemplating all my other decisions
in life i'm thinking about switching my
samsung s20 ultra to the new iphone i'm
thinking about scrapping this computer
when the new imacs come out in the
larger 27 inch models yet to be
confirmed
but i've just completely changed my
whole way of thinking about technology
because of this simple device
this device genuinely makes everything
so easy i've been able to split it up
into two categories basically dividing
it between personal life and work life
and managing that balance so much better
than i ever could before
previously i'd be carrying around my
laptop and my phone and having my work
emails on one and my personal emails on
one another and then having all my
business essentials on a completely
third device
now i've been able to integrate that so
seamlessly and so smoothly in the m1
ipad pro
and it has been able to handle every
single task i've thrown at it not once
have i had an issue with this ipad as
yet looking at it from a pure
performance beast of a system that's the
genuine reason why i bought the ipad pro
it has been able to stand up to the test
of time i use this thing religiously
throughout the day i'll wake up like i
said i'll pick up my ipad and from about
7 30 till about 9 p.m there'll be some
sort of activity being done on this ipad
either be marking up architectural plans
going through 3d plans with clients or
even doing ar tours with the actual ipad
i'm using a hell of a lot of ram and as
much battery life as i can possibly chew
i don't think there's been a time just
yet where i've completely drained the
battery i have come very very close and
that's because i left it open on my desk
whilst i was working on my computer
absolute max brightness and just left it
on all day it lasted about six hours
before it completely died
but i learned my lesson pretty quick
just simply drag that brightness down to
at least 75
and it lasts forever i think i could
easily use this ipad two days straight
maybe even pushing it to three days
straight of general day-to-day
activities and not have to charge it
which has been a phenomenal advantage
that i didn't even know i really needed
an ipad because i do charge it every
single night but knowing that you're
going to be able to make it through that
entire day with one single charge has
been game changing from the performance
side as well like i said i've been doing
a lot of ar and a lot of vr with this
system the ar capabilities with that
built-in lidar scanner have made it
incredible i'm able to bring up full 3d
models of houses of buildings of
skyscrapers and show them directly in
front of the client and present them
with something that they've never seen
before so it has been really versatile
in all sorts of aspects to be able to
really keep up with the high demand and
high graphics capabilities that i need
personally as an architect now having
said all this there are some slight cons
to the ipad pro
first of all i dropped my ipad pro
outside and it landed smack bang on a
rock
now thank god it did not crack the ipad
has a couple minor scratches somehow
absolute miracle it did not shatter into
a million pieces my heart sank when i
dropped the ipad i was on site doing a
3d lidar scan scanning
an entire environment and actually
creating a video here for youtube
then i slipped fell and dropped the ipad
i genuinely genuinely genuinely thought
i'd be picking that ipad up and looking
at an absolute nightmare of a screen
now i picked it up and to my disbelief
there was literally one tiny tiny
scratch on the screen on the corner
that basically can't even be seen from a
day-to-day operation point of view so
the durability first of all from this
ipad has been phenomenal i'm not one to
go around bashing and beating the ipad
around so i wouldn't really take my
review of durability as the best thing
ever and that you can go around throwing
it
off cliffs and
doing whatever you want with it it still
is a fragile device but it is a lot more
robust than i previously would have
anticipated which is really reassuring
considering the price tag of the device
that was literally one of the only times
that i took it out of the magic keyboard
and used it as an ipad without the magic
keyboard now the magic keyboard for me
is an accessory that i would not go
without it fundamentally changed the
ipad from being just your basic
run-of-the-mill tablet to actually being
able to replace my laptop i do have a
very very high-end laptop that cost
double what this ipad costs
and i never use it ever it literally
sits on the desk next to me never
getting used i've put it up for sale
because
it just doesn't have a purpose anymore
so the ipad has been able to replace
pretty much all of my emails on my phone
all of my emails and all of my work on a
laptop there is one major major major
downside to this ipad pro
and this is just me being pedantic and
me being picky the ipad pro in itself is
ultra light ultra slim and just
phenomenally designed however once you
magnetically click that on to the actual
magic keyboard well all of a sudden that
weight goes through the roof it
literally doubles in overall weight now
in a small little compact package you
wouldn't think too much of it but when
you have to carry this around all day
every day it does become a small little
burden now the simple fact that this
keyboard is just that little bit too
heavy is a bit disappointing
over the last six months because i do
wish that this keyboard was a little bit
lighter the keyboard in itself has
lasted phenomenally well as you see i'll
do a little bit of a b-roll here over
the top of this
the actual surfaces have lasted really
really well it gets thrown into bags
into backpacks it's been on airplanes
it's been in the little luggage
compartments it's been on the car back
seats it's been on site it's been in the
sand it's literally been everywhere that
you would take a regular notebook and a
regular notepad and it survived
everything i've spilled water on it i've
spilled coffee on it there has been some
pretty bad accidents with this ipad but
it survived it all and without a single
fault so far the only thing the ipad has
not been able to replace
is my actual architectural work on a
computer now having said that i do
believe it has the core capabilities
through the ram and the m1 chip to
actually run these programs but
unfortunately these programs aren't
available on a tablet so i can't even go
and test it out all in all would i
recommend the m1 ipad pro six months
after owning it using it every single
day basically religiously and pushing it
to its absolute limits
yes yes i 100 would recommend the ipad
pro i have not had
any genuine issues with this device that
i would go um i wish i didn't buy that
device and coming from me that's
actually a pretty big deal personally i
always buy a device and a couple months
later i go ah you know what
this wasn't the best choice or this
wasn't the best way i could have spent
my money for the first time
genuinely i think the ipad pro with the
m1 chip able to handle so much more than
it ever could before
and genuinely actually do what they
stated in the keynote has been
revolutionary and game changing and on
that note that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you got the information you were looking
for today and i do hope that the
information i provided at least provided
you with some reassurance that if you're
going to go out and spend a couple
thousand dollars on a tablet at least
you know you're going to be getting your
money's worth if you have any questions
about the ipad pro or anything we've
talked about today check out the links
in the description below there's some
good information some good resources
some discord chat so we can continue
talking about this and there is also the
comments section down below that i
obviously check all the time
if you did enjoy this video please make
sure you smash that like button and the
subscribe button the like button helps
with the youtube algorithm the subscribe
button just genuinely tells me that
you're enjoying this content and you
want to see more of it but that is
genuinely all from me so i'll see you
guys next monday